143 licenciés à saint-jean-de-la-ruelle
l'effectif de l'année passée est déjà
égalé parmi les 11 14 ans du club des
tireurs déjà aguerris et quelques
novices
j'ai toujours bien aimé un peu ce sport
là où c'est vrai qu'on se bat c'est
quand même un peu ça rapporte quelque
chose que c'est un peu ça donne envie
une envie stimuler tous les quatre ans
par les jeux olympiques en étant à la
direction je n'avais pas connu de
d'année gio et on m'avait dit tu verras
il ya une remontée des licenciés et
c'est donc la pâte gillot c'était un peu
chez tout le monde c'était un peu le
stress et on a effectivement une superbe
reprise d'années donc l'effet jiho
effectivement on en a pas là cette année
on en a pas besoin
on est content vous prenez chacun notre
piste du même côté s'il vous plaît la
hausse du nombre de licenciés tient
aussi à l'investissement d'une équipe
soucieuse de concilier différentes
pratiques du loisir à la compétition
et cet été le club a communiqué autour
des spécificités sanitaire de l'escrim
notre fédération avait déjà communiqué
sur le port du masque en disant voilà
que ce serait bien de changer de masque
on a accentué un peu ce set quand cette
campagne de com on l'a on expliquant que
l escrime on a déjà notre masse on a un
gant et en plus de ça la distance c'est
primordial donc voilà on a tout baser là
dessus et ça a beaucoup fait rire les
gens
alors les ans jeanne la salle maître
d'armes vous êtes également les
effectifs progresser avec une vingtaine
de tout jeunes escrimeurs son groupe a
doublé en quatre ans par une année rude
et joe durant l'été ça se ressent quand
même ça se ressemble et sur la saison
qui suit on a plus deux inscrits chez
les petits de stage là par exemple ou
aussi chez les filles
quand les filles font des médailles on
remarque ya plus de filles qui
s'inscrivent sur ne croit donc là ya pas
eu ce petit bonus ya pas eu mais on
ressent pas de deux persos manque
d'effectifs
jacques à côté des plus petits les moins
de 11 ans répètent les gestes
élémentaires à l'épée ou au sabre
quelqu'un tu la tierce et la carte plus
importante après il faut savoir faire la
fente pour attaquer les marches le
retraité après il ya des techniques
compliqués pour pouvoir s'améliorer et
gagner plus
j'avais fait beaucoup de sport avant et
ça j'ai trouvé enfin le sport qui me
plaisait beaucoup
c'est peut-être la concentration et la
précision qu'il faut faire pas on est
dans un mac il ya des gens au cercle
orléanais jean-louis dénouée par
ailleurs président du comité régional
olympique
il était moins des difficultés dans
d'autres disciplines sportives
on annonce nationale et celle c'est noël
c'est rudi une baisse d'environ 25 ans
avec des disparités suivant les
disciplines ça peut aller de 50 à 80%
mais c'est vraiment inquiétant pour la
suite notamment pour la survie de cette
association
dans ce contexte les scream orléanaise
s'en sort bien
seul bémol le flou quant à
l'organisation des compétitions